Hi, in this video we're going to take a look at the tools included with Burp Suite that allow you to work with opaque data that isn't human readable.
You can use these whilst analysing the attack surface to review the information being transmitted and understand more about how the application works.
You might find that some of the opaque data contains information such as a username or a timestamp and you can test whether editing the opaque data impacts the response.
You can use the inspector and decoder within Burp to decode and work with opaque data.
To see how this works, we're going to use the Modifying Serialized Data Types lab in our Web Security Academy.
We'll take a look at the inspector first.
Once you've launched the lab, use Burp's Embedded Browser to log in and then go to Burp's Proxy HTTP History tab to identify a message that includes opaque data.
In the Proxy History tab, highlight the data you want to study.
The selected text will be shown in the inspector panel.
If Burp recognises an encoding format, it will automatically decode the data and display it in the inspector.
If the data has been decoded in the inspector panel, you can modify the decoded data in the panel to see how this impacts the response.
To test this out, right-click the request and select Send to Repeater.
Go to the Repeater tab.
Highlight the data and edit it in the inspector panel as described in the lab solution.
We're going to update the length of the username attribute to 13, change the username to Administrator, and change the access token to Integer 0.
Click on Apply Changes, and send the request.
You can now review the response to determine how the modification impacted the response.
In this case, we'll get a redirect which takes us to a page with access to the admin panel.
The next one is the number of the instructions.
The instructions are the number of the instructions.